hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Supergirl episode 2 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet whole bunch of comic
book stuff they even made a comic book
cover for the episode there are a few
things that they've confirmed about
future episodes like future characters
so I'll try to remember to mention that
at the end of this the big stuff first
this is really like the metallo episode
in setting up the dynamics going forward
like explaining kind of how things are
going to work like how the show has
changed because you have a bunch of
characters leaving you have a bunch of
characters coming on and I'm already
liking snapper car with car like their
scenes together more than I like cat
grant because Calista Flockhart great
actress but I feel like you know we'll
say number 10 snapper Carr balances out
Kara's optimism a lot more so the
cuteness that she has like when she's
trying to insult him just works a little
bit better when it doesn't faze him when
he has that kind of deadpan reaction
like he just does not give a just
completely shuts her down one of the big
reasons I think it works so well it's
just because the actor himself like you
may recognize him from other shows that
he's known for doing a lot of comedy but
I feel like the snapper Cara stuff will
be more in the tone of like Superman
Supergirl Daily Planet that you're used
to hearing more of like a parody white
relationship so number 9 other big
team-up you probably noticed in the
episode was Winn and Alex you can
probably expect them to use him in a
Cisco type way someone who's just really
excited to be there just absolutely down
for anything whereas like everybody else
takes it super seriously so I feel like
they had really good energy Martian
Manhunter like you know when he's like
stomping his foot being all pissed off
at Superman like that didn't work for me
so much but number eight the big like
super bro down they almost had like
Martian Manhunter versus Superman Winn
said it all like it was the perfect
reaction oh my god this is terrible oh
my god this is amazing the reality of
that situation is is that Superman
technically is more powerful but it
seems like this version of Martian
Manhunter on the TV show is just way
more hardcore so I wouldn't be surprised
if he came out on top because he does
have like phasing abilities that
Superman doesn't have so if there
equal fighters in martian manhunter is
just willing to fight dirty he's gonna
win it's one of the few reasons why
Batman is able to get the upper hand on
Superman it's the same argument
Superman is more powerful but he's a boy
scout so he pulls his punches other
people do not
but number six Dean Cain name drops so
they kept mentioning Alex and Cara's
father the things they said confirmed
that he was still alive but like they
say you should remember him how he used
to be not how he is now so everyone's
like hey wait a minute does that mean
they're actually gonna do the cyborg
Superman thing the John Wesley Shipp Jay
Garrick you know flash in the classic
series to another flash costume in the
modern series so like Dean Cain's
Superman to another Superman costume
persona via cyborg Superman that would
be amazing
that's not confirmed or anything they
haven't said anything about Dean Cain
this season but they mentioned him so
many times within the Cadmus labs
storyline this week that he just has to
show up in some big WTF twist and what's
bigger than cyborg Superman so just open
up a tab in chrome for that it just
feels like it's too big for them to
reveal this soon so I'm expecting a Dean
Cain revealed like whatever it is
they've done with them for us to learn
about that as we head into the
mid-season finale
but number five promethium if you don't
know what this metal is they're kind of
using it like adamantium on the TV show
but it's an actual special metal from
the DC Universe that only exists in this
limbo state the only real times it's
shown up though was during the Blue
Beetle classic comic book like the Ted
Kord Blue Beetle comic book in the old
school new Teen Titans the big twist is
that the metal has regenerative
properties so theoretically they blast
metallo the metal parts would just heal
themselves the metal exoskeletons that
you saw Supergirl Superman wearing that
you might recognize as being like
Superboy primes anti-monitor armor was
just stuff left over from season one
there was an actual like the Saint
promethium metal and if you've only seen
this image of superboy-prime you haven't
read the comics you don't know like what
this is made up so the anti-monitor
is this super powerful being from the
antimatter universe he has special
armor that he wears superboy-prime
reverse-engineered it to help him absorb
solar radiation even faster there have
been other versions of people like
metallo that have cores of kryptonite
they just do different things reactron
is like another big one that showed up
during the New Krypton storyline so
basically like cybernetic beings powered
by kryptonite powered by things that can
hurt or kill Kryptonians so at the end
of the episode if it wasn't clear they
didn't kill these two metallo suspense
John Corben like you want to keep him on
so that he can come back looking even
more freakish in the back half of the
season and of course the iconic crisis
on Infinite Earths death of Supergirl
cover they even released this comic book
version like they did last year for the
flash they had the comic book cover for
the Supergirl crossover every once in a
while they do this for certain episodes
I'm expecting them to do it for the four
night crossover too with the dominators
but number three cat grant is leaving
the show you may have known about this
during the summer that they announced
that Calista Flockhart just wasn't going
to be making the move to Vancouver with
the rest of the actors and the crew so
like they moved the show to Vancouver so
a lot of the LA actors that they had
guest star or were in season 1 will not
come back with the exception like the
really big ones cat grant will come back
a couple times during this season but I
feel like all the changes they made to
the show in front of the camera and
behind the camera will make it much
better so number 2 is Superman leaving
so if it wasn't clear Superman is not
going to be on every single episode I
feel like most people understood that I
don't know exactly how many times he'll
come back during the season but I'm
expecting at least once more before the
end but they do have the fortress of
solitude Cara went there last year so
there'll be a bunch of Superman things
happening metropolis will still be there
so number one of course is the Mon El
WTF at the end he'll be in the next
episode we'll actually hear him speak
learn about what the show's gonna do
with him I'm effectively calling him the
Superboy of this TV show but I don't
know if they're gonna use that name
there might just be some jokes about
Superboy
but like during the episode when you
heard them expose him to kryptonite they
said there was a power drain
they'll learn about the
Maxo mites as they go along like
Superman sounds like he has an idea but
he doesn't fully understand where Mon L
is from the nebula he's from in how his
powers will be slightly similar but not
quite the same thing
so the big difference with Mon L in the
comics I don't know they're gonna do it
exactly like the comics but he has
virtually all the same powers is
Superman and Supergirl with a weakness
to lead instead of kryptonite so we'll
just see how the TV show changes that
they'll probably explain all the
important stuff upfront and I think you
know so talking about the rest of the
stuff that's happening Lynda Carter
president Wonder Woman next week there's
gonna be no show that she guest stars on
where she is not the strongest person in
the room if you guys don't know who
Lynda Carter is she was like the 1970s
Wonder Woman so each time she's gone on
like a comic book or genre TV show
they've always had references and jokes
about the fact that she's super powerful
without actually saying the name Wonder
Woman so just look for lots of Wonder
Woman Easter eggs when she comes next
week but let me know what was your
favorite thing about the episode and
everybody's waiting for Miss Martian to
show up too that's another big character
Miss Martian will be on season 2 but
like the next big arc is gonna be an a
climatic ma Nell to Earth culture and
they just said it's not gonna go well at
all he's supposed to be like this
old-school dude so just look forward to
him like shutting Kara down like snapper
Carr in really hilarious ways but so far
I'm liking what they're doing with
Cadmus I'm curious to see where Jimmy
guardians stuff shows up like where he
gets that armor just think of Cadmus is
like the evil version darkest timeline
version of STAR Labs who are just
hell-bent getting rid of aliens on the
planet and there will be a lot of cosmic
characters appearing during season 2 but
I feel like the real test of season 3
especially you know whether or not I'm
gonna keep doing videos for it is gonna
be episode 3 because they won't have
Superman so we'll just see how that goes
next week because there aren't like a
bunch of shows that I've fallen behind
on and I can't make videos for every
single thing so usually I have to pick
and choose so if I know something's
gonna be awesome I'll just stick it into
my schedule I know a lot more about
what's happening this season on the
flash than I do about the other shows
but we're starting to learn a little bit
or about the four night crossover
especially from the legends side of
things because that shows only just
started too so just to society on
legends of tomorrow this week be sure to
subscribe to get that video in fact
there's actually a new round of the
giveaway that's going on right now the
DC giveaway is a $20 Amazon gift card
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so what's gonna happen is is next
DC video will be flash tomorrow night
I'm gonna try and get Luke Cage out
before then well you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for my Jesse
quick flash trailer and you can click
here to learn all about what's going on
with spider-man homecoming thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight